[Music]
have you guys heard of
figgs scrubs yeah yeah what is that oh
yes the clothing for um medical workers
we sponsored our podcast hella times
oh are they going out of business like
soap with like food that's what i think
bits in it
like seeds but then i remember no no
no no no no no i'm nervous no no no
no no no no no no no no i don't want to
hear this no no what's going on what
about it what about it
well i have a couple pair of the pants
too and it's comfortable oh yeah fake
pants yeah they sent it to me oh no oh
jio gave me a pair but they were too
small
oh yeah i never even seen this okay
well anyway i've seen the billboards
they have billboards
i've never even seen this big scrub all
about
all about to show you oh thank you
[Laughter]
the jomalien came out no no
no no all right so uh fig scrubs here
they
posted on their social media this ad
that i'm about to show you
oh no and it got some crazy background
oh
dear oh my god i'm actually kind of
excited just to see what the hell's
going on so
fyi there is no audio okay all right she
goes the [ __ ] it's company before
i'll never heard it never sponsored do
we don't need it
uh because the person who recorded it
just didn't get the audio or whatever
like on social media oh because they
don't they deleted it so
whatever we got is what we got okay
i like the stuff for me it's medical for
dummies
no no no no no no no no no okay okay
yes nice those scrubs are kind of cute
yeah yeah
yeah but what what are they going to
compare it to right now
so wait what was that so
it says medical terminology for dummies
yeah and it it says
d-o right which means doctor of
osteopathy
yeah still bone doctor uh no it's
i think it's like a it's like a more
holistic way of looking at medicine
osteopathic but it's interchangeable
mddo what's the bone one
ortho ortho b oh that's an md but then
their specialty
is orthopedics so she's reading a book
that says medical terminology for
dummies
upside down by the way the books upside
down yes so saying that women was dumb i
thought she's just a student
why is the book upside down and why is
it medical terminology oh cause she was
an influencer
so is it saying wait what's going on
what's wrong are people mad because like
she looks cute and that means she can't
be smart
i'm getting it so basically the books
upside down women are stupid
right wait you think women are stupid
that's [ __ ] up no that's what that's
insinuating so that that narrative is
pretty [ __ ] up they were waiting for
someone to say it and then blame them
so the people that are getting mad are
assuming that
wait she hasn't even told us yet uh yeah
well yeah that's basically what it is
so basically so people are claiming that
this is very sexist
because of the fact that it's a girl
right and she's upside like holding the
book upside down
she's dumb it's also the medical
terminology for dummies
on top of that and also it's d.o
which is doctor of osteopathic medicine
which is which they take a more holistic
approach to diseases a pros
opposed to doctors with nd's medical
degree oh
like they're not good enough for mds
yeah they do it holistically yeah so
they're pretty much like
they're pretty much [ __ ] on women
doctors and
people look so much interesting that's
funny wait i saw it was like oh cool
there's a really cool shade of pink
the cut looks very slim it's a cool
cut-off what do you think
no but the actual prop though the upside
down book that says medical terminology
for dummies is pretty [ __ ] blatant
like
i wasn't even looking at the props
because that's that's like me like
looking at a car commercial like oh my
god you see the [ __ ] trees on the
side
no [ __ ] joshua trees no because here
they're actually like
using the prop to they're telling a
story but you're telling me figs right
so i'm still looking at the scrubs
sure but but the prop also is part of
the entire ad because it's a complete
background they are making a point maybe
i'm dumb dude
so i'm sure everything upside down i
took it more as
um there's so many people think that
they're doctors nowadays
because of all the holistic and
alternative ways of being medical
that it's like hey at least you can look
like a doctor even though we didn't
actually go to school for this [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
i didn't take it as like this girl is
dumb um
because she's a girl i took it as these
new ways of studying
which is still dissing all the d.o well
yeah
right well if anything exactly so the
point is they're just if anything's
[ __ ] on someone
the marketing just like they missed they
missed something because
if anything she should have been not in
the scrubs reading the book upside down
oh
naked and then what did you want
sexualizing her
and then when she puts on the scrubs and
then when she puts on the scrubs
oh it makes her a smart and a real
doctor like oh duh
that's good that would have been the
[ __ ] at least something some type of
message
slightly with the upside down book
though exactly that was always like a
dumb blonde joke right right she's like
i love to read
now brunette can be done too apparently
that's inclusive now the joke
yeah true no but honestly that's just
like very blatantly
like women doctors are i just thought
they're just [ __ ]
right bless you bless you that's great
yeah i mean i don't know you on first
watch that's how you took it yeah for
sure like they're like saying that
what girl doctors are basically saying
females
are dumb that's the umbrella wow i guess
i don't think like the normal person
because i didn't
i didn't think it went straight to
females or dumb literally medical
terminology for dummies and it's upside
down yeah i did i didn't i didn't think
i didn't think it was uh dumb females
yeah i thought it was like
well actually like bart i didn't see the
book and then the d.o
so uh because my eyes are kind of blurry
so i just saw her holding the book and
looking cute in the scrub and i was like
oh wow those are some nice scrubs
okay that's perfectly fine but then you
just take
now the information that you have at
hand how do you interpret
just this like i i understand
that perspective for sure uh where like
women
are offended but like even when i
because like as
a not medical person at all right i
don't know what the [ __ ] a doe is yeah
so i still feel like it's marketed
towards more like
medical people that part i missed i
don't know that interchangeable with
md like there's does at kaiser
permanente usc
hospital cedar sinai there's deals all
over the place right is it like being a
chiropractor
in the medicine world the same thing as
an md pretty soon can they prescribe
different approaches yes they can it's
the same same approach
so they're not different they're not
crystal readers no
they go to medical school like like
western university in pomona like
she's so being a deo is it like being a
physician's assistant it's or being an
rn it's a title
being an md really yeah like rns msns
but you're saying they don't get the
level of respect nurse practitioners
answered the deal still
oh yeah i just i didn't know that part
yeah i didn't know either
okay cause the way that tiff explained
it i thought it was just some like
chiropractor or someone who's kind of in
the gray area
well that's how they wrote it in the
article that they take a more holistic
approach to medicine versus
mds hmm oh
that's what it means okay holistic
approach doesn't mean like
cookie no holistic just means
alternative to
pills yeah because medicine is like
surgery and pills yeah so like md it's
like okay you have
this i'm gonna write an exact pill then
they'll consider your whole lifestyle
first
are you sleeping enough are you doing
this enough so it's more like like a
holistic actual holistic approach
so it's not like here's this medicine
that you go take right now
so that's why like on like hearing the
article and [ __ ] it makes me feel like
oh this is more like a
like we're medical people laughing at
these people who think they're on our
level
it's like an inside joke within the
medical community almost personally
my my first initial response to this
wasn't the woman thing
it was the they're talking [ __ ] about
the deals
in the hospital you're the probably the
closest one to the medical world here
like did you hear those jokes coming
from people like
like they were joking about the do's uh
i wasn't
involved in that section of the house oh
i actually never even heard of this
career personally
so i wasn't fully aware of what this is
i just saw like d.o
i'm like well whatever d.o means making
it seem like they're dummies
that's that's how i equated it and then
i read the article
and then they were like what the [ __ ]
like i'm studying for d.o or whatever
like
[ __ ] you when i look at that book it
just reminds me of when they left the
coffee cup in that one episode of game
of thrones
but it wasn't upside down yeah but i'm
like it's like i don't know continuity
like i know there's so many layers
that i we're
like they did use a specific zoom in on
the d.o
badge right and they're like making it a
point to be like
hey this person is a deal it's a do and
hey
they're they're they're also adults i
just saw it as their their scrubs are so
stylish it doesn't actually look like
scrubs to me
and they needed something to indicate
that this is a medical professional
and maybe they had access to a do badge
not an md bag
so when it comes to like producing
things i'm like
sometimes you just have access to the
then it's like why is the book upside
down
i don't know jon snow had a [ __ ]
coffee oh so you're saying it was
accidentally upside down and someone on
the prop
i don't know for me i have so many
layers of benefit of doubt before it
gets to these [ __ ] i'm trying
to insult people
because you're not a woman or a d.o bart
i'm nice maybe i don't know
i mean i don't know yeah as someone
who's never worn scrubs
yeah i don't want no scrubs that's if
anything
no scrubs aren't don't see all these
lines those one pants that didn't fit me
they were really soft
they were right yeah they were pretty
comfy i guess there is also the
narrative of like
like you'll look like a doctor no matter
what if you wear these scrubs that
what you read doesn't matter right in
terms of the figs
we need to ask the marketing person what
the [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] were you
trying to do you dumbass
yeah what did figs respond with well we
did tweet out they said
we dropped the ball and we are so sorry
we love you guys and we'll always listen
to what you have to say that's what they
said it's like a drunk it's like a drunk
tweet
go fig go fig you know no
that doesn't say anything i do have to
point out the fact that figs
is a company that was founded by two
women
and so that's where they [ __ ] up and
so like that is
just the piece of information you might
want to have that is interesting to have
actually i wish you brought that up
sooner
does that change anything that does
change it's okay you and me making that
commercial it's like why
yeah right so because cotton know it
that's like someone reading this one i
think it was just a mistake holding the
bottle upside down the whole time
i don't know what if it was just a
stupid-ass mistake that's how i view it
there's no way in hell that is such a
blatant baby maybe it was two women
because you know how women are so catty
then they were like that [ __ ] barbara
from med school was a d.o
and that [ __ ] was dumb as [ __ ] like an
easter egg just to like throw shade at
barbara
yeah yeah it was a personal vendetta
idiots they just offended a whole like
group of people with yeah yeah so what
are these groups of people saying
what i was telling you well that is true
though because i can see women like
let's say for example
i dated the guy who invented the dummies
books
and like it's actually you know little
things like that i guess i could see us
doing something
though people like to jump to
conclusions no but that this one's
pretty clear personally i still think
it's so clear that like they [ __ ] up
the upside down book yeah they signed
that upside down book
like and if it was right up then it
could be more of a stretch
what if it was a dude if it was a dude
i wouldn't be offended first of all
really i
i for me it could be entertainable who
would it who's wearing it it's just the
fact that it's like the upside down book
it's four dummies
d.o it's like so you focus more on the
d.o
people being disrespectful yeah instead
of it being gender i think so
i don't know anything about the do life
it's just not a good joke
yeah i think i'm more offended about how
confusing and stupid it is no they
really did drop the ball
because i'm just like if you made me
spend over 10 minutes right now trying
to decipher your shitty marketing ad
[Laughter]
now i'm pissed because i'm confused what
you were trying to make yeah
what point are you trying to make as a
comedian
disrespecting the art i know dude
you